good morning good afternoon and hello
everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
floral type technology as a reliable
diagnostic tool during covid19
and flu season i'm alexis krauss of
labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lapperts
and sponsored by brooker daltonix
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
brooker.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click on the send button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
today alina mex
senior product manager for a complete
biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
alina you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much alexis for
introduction
so today i want to talk about fluorotype
technology
a reliable diagnostic tool during covet
19
and the flu season
first off i'd like to give a brief
introduction about who we are
hind life science is a company based in
the south of germany
and they are developing and producing
molecular diagnostic tests
they started off with so-called line
probe essays at the beginning
and later on they also developed pcr
based
technologies such as the fluorotype
technology they also developed
their own instruments to use those
diagnostic tests
in 2018 hind life science became a
broker company
and together with broker we continue to
develop
innovative diagnostics and the devices
the heart of the technology is the
fluorocyto xt
it is a pcr instrument that is
very precise and it can be used very
flexibly
you can run it with up to 96 parallel
samples
it has up to five detection channels
depending on your need or depending on
the essay you want to run
with this device and there are already a
couple
of molecular diagnostic tests that are
compatible with this instrument quite a
nice portfolio with more essays
to come
so today we want to talk about the
fluorotab cells
cop2 plus
which is a multiplex real-time pcr essay
that you can use for your code with 19
diagnostics
flask of two plus detects sparse genes
with two
individual targets if you look on the
right you can see that we are detecting
the rdrp
gene and the n gene
we also tried to focus here on target
sequences that have a low risk
fermentation occurrence to make this
assay
very reliable additionally we are
detecting
human coronaviruses and we can
differentiate them
against sars cough too
this essay provides fast results that
you can trust
it is 100 specific the combination
between
our very powerful hardware and software
allow a detection of the size cuff 2 rna
down to just
1.2 copies per ml
and we have certainty of every step in
the workflow because
we use an internal control that monitors
from extraction to analysis for cov
testing
our internal control is an enveloped rna
and it mimics viral particles so it
creates very realistic conditions when
it comes
to the lysosome during the extraction
also
the reverse transcription and the
amplification
at the end of the reaction
so how exactly can we assure such
reliable results what is the key
it's basically our software with fluoro
software it's tidy
are using an automated analysis
to end the bias
so let us focus a little bit on cp value
because they have been discussed
recently when it comes to sask of 2
diagnostic
what does cp or ct value actually mean
so there are two
terms that can be used interchangeable
cp
stands for crossing point and ct
stands for cycle threshold and if you
look
at the graph on the left you see pcr
cycles plotted against
fluorescence and you see what is a
typical real-time
pcr curve so if we would
now look at the two different methods
that can be used
to calculate the p-value there is
the first approach which is called the
threshold method
this is basically the point where
the fluorescence first leaves the
background signal
and this can be on different
places on the curve depending on how you
interpret that
and the second approach would be just
using the point of inflection of that
curve and if you now compare these two
approaches you already see
that the cp values that you obtain using
either method
can differ so it depends on the method
that you use
and if we are looking at the threshold
method itself
it also depends on where you set the
threshold and where you define
where the curve now crosses the
background
so cp values differ
depending on how the value is obtained
so there is no consensus and no guidance
when it comes to cp values
multiple factors can impact or bias the
cp values
for example it depends on the pcr cycle
that you're using
the user that is evaluating the cp value
and also the daily form of that user
can depend on the software that is used
the protocol and the
essay the test itself and all these
factors
can bias the cp value
now we are using plural software and
with fluoro software we are
using an automated cp value calculation
that can put an end to all of this bias
but why are cp values so important well
many health care systems worldwide
establish
guidelines for patient management based
on
cp values so for example they would have
an infected
patient that would be tested positive
for south korea virus
and this patient would undergo isolation
and then in order to decide whether or
not this patient can be dismissed
they would perform pcr testing and the
pcr result would have to be either
negative or the cp value of that result
would have to be greater
than a certain value
so with fluorotype we use a fully
automated result evaluation
which completely removes the personal
bias
therefore we have maximum security and
reliable results
the system is made up of three parts the
software
which calculates the cp value
automatically using
normal and novel algorithm for threshold
evaluation
and it also provides very consistent
evaluation
the results are easy to interpret you
can basically
see them at a class the second part is
our pcr device fluorocycle xt
which is a high precision instrument
and the third part is the essay itself
fluorotype sask of two plus
with the dual target detection that i
already mentioned
and with the internal control that
provides full control across the entire
workflow
but how can we further use this system
in the current situation
in this winter season we are basically
challenged with two major problems
influenza season hits during the
corona pandemic so this poses a very
central question
is it covet or is it flu and this
question
raises many challenges
for the clinician they have to decide
which therapy
they have to give to the patient and
which emergency measures
to take for the diagnostic laboratories
they have to implement additional tests
and put in
additional effort
and lastly for the manufacturers of
molecular diagnostics
it bears multiple technical challenges
and we accepted the challenge to develop
a new diagnostic essay to tackle all
those
major problems and therefore we are very
pleased to present
a new essay which brooker will shortly
launch
fluorotype stars cop2 flew rsv
your diagnostics for the winter needs
this is again a multiplex real-time pcr
essay it can differentiate between
flu a and b directly from respiratory
samples
and it also has a very high test
capacity
it detects common winter viruses flu
rsv and also south koftu
so you can see here the four targets
that are detected with this essay it's a
nice panel of
respiratory viruses
we have again the dual target approach
for the south cup 2 genes
and we have also included the
differentiation of
influencer a and b into this essay
if you look at the graphs below this is
just a result
example and i'm pretty sure you can
already see
how easy the interpretation is at a
class
with our automated result evaluation
that has been done
by the software
in challenging times like this it is
even more
important to be in close contact with
our users
to support them in the best possible way
we are in close contact with our
customers
we are collaborating with them for
product validation
and we also provide customized solutions
we are really reliant on the input and
the feedback of our customers
and we then can react to local
regulatory guidelines
and also to current needs that our
customers might have
thanks very much for listening and we
are taking your questions now
thank you alina for your informative
presentation
i would also like to introduce andreas
weissner who will be joining us for the
live q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just simply click on the ask a question
box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
why is there three pluses in the output
of the software yeah thanks a lot alexis
and also thanks uh alina so the three
pluses give us an
indication of how strong the infection
is this is basically the calculated
value order the extrapolated value from
the
from the pcr cycles which means if there
is a higher load
earlier detected with a lower ct value
then we can consider this a strong
infection if you want so
perfect thank you andreas and now so our
next question is
um when will it appear
um well we're currently still in some
validation studies that we're doing but
we
are very hopeful within the next two to
four weeks to have the product on the
market
um kind of more of a follow-up to this
question um
is broker does does burger have any
other products
in the pipeline right now um
yes in all facets i wouldn't i wouldn't
really
inform too much about this what i can
say i think at this point
is that we are very very keen
to leverage the full potential of the
flu recycler xt
you've seen what what alina presented
with the with the five channels that we
have
and obviously we will be trying to um
to expand uh the
essays that we will have there um if i
wanna if
i do give a little bit of a sneak
preview
one of the things we will be looking
into and that we have basically with
this
uh fluorotype suskov to
influenza rsv is that we're heading more
towards the the syndromic panels
but we're certainly not going to
restrict ourselves
to the respiratory indications only
wonderful so now in the respiratory
panel
you detect sars kovi ii with two targets
however the detection is done through
one channel
how is this dual target detection
achieved
so that's a very technical question i
have to admit
i might be a little bit going out on the
limb here
it does still give the the result of
both targets
but it combines them together in one
channel
due to how the the the technology is
uh is designed and how we do the reading
and the analysis
we can extract uh the information on
both
by the separate um sorry
um we can detect that that if we can
differentiate between the two
but it does not differentiate in the in
this combo essay where we have the
the saskof2 combined with the flu and
the influenza so
we're using separate channels on the ft
saskoff two plus two
perfect thank you so much andreas so now
moving on to our next question
can the sars covi2 plus or flue rsv
kit be used with a third-party pcr
instrument
technically yes but what we would need
on
in that case is a color compensation kit
as you can
as you can imagine the the um
specifications of the individual
instruments are
are quite different and one thing that
we
do very well and i think we're fairly
almost unique in the market with our
instrument is that we have a five
channel detection
and we can separate these channels quite
well uh most of the other instruments i
could think of
are more in the well maximum of four
channel
uh area which means we would need to and
we're looking into this
provide a something that we usually call
call a color compensation kit um
that would make sure that the
wavelengths and the excitation
um that that we get in other readers
are can be analyzed by our software
and therefore sorry not by ourselves can
be used with our
essay and therefore provide the same
results
it's kind of like an adapter that you
would know on your tv
perfect so now moving on to our next
question
um is it ivd
or ruo for fluorotype sars kovi
ii flu rsv
so the the ft saskoff 2 to
rsv influenza the sort of combi
essay that we have will be an ivd
product
asset we're expecting it to be out in
about two to four weeks
perfect looking forward to it so now
moving on to our next question
the extraction does that have to be done
outside
and not in the fluorocycle fluorocycler
xt
oh that would be really really nice if
we had the extraction and
the analysis all in one instrument but
believe me the instrument would then
become very very expensive
and you also might just block the
analyzer because you're still in the
extraction step
so to give a short answer no it cannot
be done inside you usually
either do a manual extraction or you
would use
an extraction automation instrument
similar as we have for example for the
smaller
for the smaller number the geno extract
perfect so moving on to our next
question andreas
what parts of the diagnostic process
does the internal control cover
what parts of the diagnosis are the
internal control yes absolutely sorry um
that was a bit of a mouthful of a
question to digest
um so in principle the internal control
as alina said
is basically rna encapsulated and
therefore mimics the virus
now we can't control obviously with the
internal control
how the sample has been taken from the
patient
now the entire process like putting a
swap
up your nose hopefully missing the brain
and taking nasopharyngeal
uh sample that is something that cannot
be fully
controlled because this is down to to
well
a human step but the moment where you
actually have to sample in a tube and
you start the extraction
you're running the control in parallel
and therefore you can have
a full on control over the entire
process from there on
and thereby see whether what the quality
of your of your output is
so just as a reminder to our audience as
we are going through these questions we
number one we want to thank you for all
these amazing questions that are coming
in
but we do want to just remind you that
any questions that we do not have a
chance to get to today and those that
come in during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information that you
provided
at the time of registration so let's
move on to
our next question oh perfect here's one
is there an internal control positive
control
and negative control provided in the kit
so yes we do have the negative control
this is the internal control
a positive sorry no we have the positive
control which is the internal control we
do not have
a negative control in there
perfect now moving on to our next one
um how do
uh oh here we go how do people
that do not have an automated analysis
get the right cp value
well you see i'm being careful not to
say not
at all because i mean obviously there's
a lot of people out there that
still do uh facilitated or completely
manual cp value
determination and i have to say they do
not necessarily need to be bad but they
will be biased
um so if you have somebody working in an
in
a diagnostic laboratory who has been
interpreting those pcr curves
for years and years and they just know
the assay that they're working with they
know the pcr cycle that they're working
with
i will not never say that these people
will not
provide an accurate recommendation to
the doctor
but the moment where that person is out
sick
for a day and somebody else has to jump
in
even if that other person has the same
amount of experience
it is a different person and therefore
there will be a slight variation
now in many cases in passing on the the
diagnosis
or the analysis to the doctor it might
not make that much of a difference
but especially at times like these where
we have such a high throughput
um of of uh samples due to the cover 19
uh uh see well season pandemic sorry the
flu season's coming
the pandemic is still here um this
becomes
actually quite a relevant uh bias that
that is difficult to deal with otherwise
perfect thank you so much okay so moving
on to our next question
uh looks like this is a two-part
question
uh do you have floral cyclers on uh in
stock
and how long do we have to wait after
ordering one
so the ordering time i do not
know from the top of my head that has a
couple of
um that has a couple of of uh parameters
and
the first one simply being um are you
ordering directly with us
or via one of our highly valued
distributors that we
that we have in the market as well we do
have flu recycler xt in stock
um so they're all basically sitting and
waiting for
a new home there is a couple of
let's say the peripherals that we that
that are available from third parties
where we currently sometimes see a
little bit of a delay in the delivery
okay all right so we'll move on
to our next question um
in regards to um the influenza a and
influenza b
do you distinguish between the two
um yes we actually do so you remember
earlier when i said
if we talk about saskof2 um in this
ft task of two plus essay we we detect
we differentiate in different channels
we don't do that for the f
for the sask of two in the respiratory
combo essay but
we do it differentiate between influenza
types
a and influenza types b on flu b for
example we would cover the yamagata line
and the victoria line
on influenza a it's the
the hemoglutinin and the neural amides
subtypes
wonderful now why is the cp value used
to decide
about the dismissal of the patient if it
is so biased
the question that we asked ourselves as
well i mean in principle this was a
guidance
given out in in various countries we
like for example germany by the by the
uh robert koch institution rki
they've been far more differentiated in
their communication about it and they
basically said listen guys
the cp value has a bias but if you need
to communicate something on because at
the moment with the high throughput it
is just
it is just really difficult to boil it
down to one very specific
um other value they recommend to use
this
but they've also chosen a cp value of 30
as alina has shown
which is already a very high ct value so
they're trying to be just simply on the
safe side
wonderful so just a quick reminder to
our audience i know we have been asking
a lot
you guys have been asking a lot of
questions and we are so grateful
grateful for all of these questions
coming in any questions
again that we don't have time for today
and during the on-demand period which we
will send you an email when it's
available for replay you can come back
anytime to re-watch the presentation
and then please feel free to continue to
ask questions they will be
asked by or excuse me they will be
answered by the speakers
with that email that you provided during
registration
so let's move on to a another question
oh here's one right here so which
countries will the uh will the assay for
sars and the flu be available
so at the moment and our primary focus
is really to support the market where
where it's needed and the flu season is
starting
in the northern hemisphere obviously
we've been working with a lot of
customers together and even though
normally the flu season is more towards
let's say november december
sometimes even january a lot of our
customers have highlighted that
due to the very similar symptoms they're
expecting to get a lot of diagnostic
requests already in october meaning now
and certainly in november
so we've taken this into consideration
just to make sure that
we supply the market first that we can
support the best the quickest that needs
it
so initially it's going to be launched
primarily in europe
um due to the high demand that we have
from our direct customers
the the this if you if you buy via one
of our distributes you will probably
have to wait
a tiny bit longer if i say a tiny bit
longer i'm not talking about months i'm
really talking more about
a a couple of weeks and we will be then
seeing to make the the product also
available in the southern hemisphere but
more towards
february march next year um hopefully
um with the how the pandemic goes and
hopefully the flu season and starting to
to go down we can balance the needs in
the market well
now our next question is a two-part
question so
the first part is what is the number of
copies
of sarskov virus that the kit can detect
and the second aspect is what is the
maximum
number of samples that the cycler can
process
so i start with the second question
while i'm searching for the slide that
alina already had so
the flu recycler xt can handle up to 96
samples in parallel and
i'm not quite sure i now clicked on
slide 9. i hope you see that that slide
fighting copied 19 floor types ask of
two plus
so the um the number of copies that we
can identify is 1.2
copies per microliter
perfect now moving on to our next one
um the internal control it
is it endogenous or exogenous
uh oh technical thing i have a i have
i have my cheat sheet open on the side
let me have a quick
look if i uh i have to say i'm not a
technical specialist here um if i see
that correctly um this would be an
endogenous
control perfect
now is it validated for other real-time
pcr systems
so other real-time pcr systems that
could be used here
are or let's see other cyclists would be
the abi
75 7500 cfx 96
rotating queue quant studio five
so that is also from my cheat sheet so i
hope that satisfies
the question i'm sure it does
uh so let's how about this one
now can the fluorocycler 96 also do
the sars kovi 2 plus instead of the
fluorocycle or xt
i wish it could but it can't one of the
reasons
is that we have a fairly huge
update or actually physical updates not
just software we actually revamped a lot
of the
the internal um technology within the
floor recycler xt
um especially when it comes to the the
light pathways
um how we detect it and um
this is a technology that actually
really positions us also going forward
i mentioned the syndromic panels a
little bit earlier
and therefore the way how we've
developed this specific
assay would not allow to run it on a
fluorocyclo96
okay thank you so much for that
clarification andreas
so moving on to our next question
here we go what was special about the
two independent sars genes that you have
chosen
oh so so there were two reasons why we
took two in the first place and
and i think alina mentioned this at an
at an earlier stage
um the reason here was you always want
to have a safety net
if one isn't detected you still get the
signal from the other one
and if you remember from the nice curse
where basically almost
anyone could read out uh what the result
is
it would then highlight you very clearly
that one channel is detected positive
while the other one is detected
negatively
um but in addition to this and and
i'm comparing this now to other tests
that we've seen in the markets the genes
that we've used
are um also let's say special or
different um in
in two other ways first of all um
they're both
not in the envelope uh of the of the
virus
and the envelope is just known to go
undergo far higher mutation rates so
this gives us a certain
um a certain safety going forward with
the virus
i don't want to say evolving because
that sounds far too big but at least
mutating generating new strains as we've
already seen
in some of the the um
the data that was published about force
four to six weeks ago
um and i mean it's it's never it's never
a
safe uh 100 safety that the genes that
we've chosen
would not mutate but we've chosen them
really in a way that it makes it far
likely
than some of the other genes that we
know are the basis for
um for the um
a basis for the diagnostic detection
perfect so looks like we have time for a
couple more or maybe about one more one
more questions let's find
here we go so it was stated that the
assay was rapid
what is the actual time from sample to
result
from sample to result well i think
taking the sample would be fairly
quick um and going back to the nas
wrinkles swap
but it depends also a lot on the
extraction um the extraction
that we have with some of our systems
now well maybe maybe let's start on the
let's start on the the
pcr first the pcr itself
would generate the
would generate the results um in
about an hour and 15 minutes to one and
a half hours
and on the extraction if you do it in an
automated way
it has really it just really depends how
how fast your your automated uh
extraction
instrument is we have um the latino
extracts that i can refer
to i only can do 12 samples i
i i'll just estimate a little bit longer
than the geno extract that we have
so i would say probably in the range of
45 to
minutes to one hour so all together you
would be able to expect the results from
putting the sample into your process to
the result of about
two and two to two and a half hours but
then you have a very very clear result
already so that also includes the actual
well automated analysis as mentioned
wonderful thank you so much andreas
before we go
i would like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information that you provided at the
time of registration
we would like to once again thank alina
for her time today and her important
research we would also like to thank
andreas for joining us and answering all
of those questions that the audience had
today
we would also like to thank labyrinths
and our spon our sponsor brooker
deltonix for underwriting today's
educational webcast you can view this
webinar on demand
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for today please join us next
week for part
three of our webinar series serious
launches on the maldi bio typer and more
until next time have a great rest your
day
stay safe and stay healthy bye bye
everyone